[Music]  one of the fastest growing areas here in  waimakarari  is the northeast with wood in ravenswood  and of course pegasus  [Music]  we currently rent space here in pegasus  for community activities  but really it's too small so the council  is  proposing to buy land and build new  community centres  for these areas the council's preferred  option is to buy land  and build a community centre in pegasus  starting next year  then around 2028 by land and ravenswood  and build another community facility  there  alternatively we could build both  facilities  within the next five years or we could  build  one large centre to cater for all areas  including wood end and that could be  either here at ravenswood  or at pegasus visit waimakariri.govt  dot nz forward slash let's talk  to look at the options and to have your  [Music]  say  you